okay
this
um
okay
uh
so
uh
two minute warning on the press briefing
two minute warning of the press briefing
thank you
uh
you're there
i think i'm actually the camera
don't worry
hi everyone hello
hello okay couple items
for all of you at the top first welcome
andrew bates our new w press secretary
anyone who covered
uh the biden campaign knows andrew quite
well
and he just joined our team after being
staying on the transition
for the last two months um
okay this wednesday the president will
be laying out the first of two equally
critically
critical packages to rebuild our economy
and create
better paying jobs for american workers
he'll talk this week about investments
we need to make in domestic
manufacturing
r d the caregiving economy and
infrastructure
in the coming weeks the president will
lay out his vision for a second package
that focuses squarely on creating
economic security for the middle class
through investments in child care health
care education and other areas
throughout this process we look forward
to working with a broad coalition of
members of congress to gather their
input and ideas and determine the path
forward create good jobs
and make america more competitive i also
note that he's doing this in pittsburgh
where he
launched his campaign for the presidency
just two years ago
today the cdc also announced a 90-day
extension of the federal eviction
moratorium the news was out earlier
today the moratorium was scheduled to
expire on march 31st and is now extended
through june 30th
the president is committed to supporting
renters and small landlords through the
covet 19
crisis essential to that effort is of
course the american rescue plan
which delivers an additional 21.5
billion in emergency rental assistance
to help millions of families keep up on
rent and remain
in their homes this of course is an act
that included
uh coordination from the treasury
department from hud from the usda
the cfpb and the ftc they're all
coordinating efforts
today the white house convened leaders
from across the administration as t
and is taking coordinated steps to
announce a set of bold actions
that will catalyze offshore wind energy
and create good paying
union jobs the president recognizes that
a thriving offshore wind industry
will drive new jobs and economic
opportunity up and down the atlantic
coast in the gulf of mexico
and in pacific waters we just released a
fact sheet on this announcement pretty
detailed
the department of interior interior
energy and commerce are
now announced a shared goal to deploy 30
gigawatts of offshore wind in the united
states by 2030
while protecting biodiversity and
protecting ocean coal use
meeting this target will trigger more
than 12 billion dollars per year in
capital investment
in projects on both u.s coasts create
tens of thousands of good
paying union jobs with more than 44 000
workers employed in offshore wind by
2030 and nearly 33 000 additional jobs
in communities
supported by offshore wind activity
it will also generate enough power to
meet the demand of more than 10 million
american homes and avoid 78 million
metric tons
tons of carbon emissions additionally
the us department of treasury's maritime
administration today is announcing a
notice of funding
opportunity for port authorities and
other applicants to apply for
230 million dollars for port and
intermodal infrastructure related
projects through the port infrastructure
development program last item uh is i
have uh
some an update for you on the flooding
that has occurred in the tennessee
valley
the department of homeland security and
media sources report for fatalities
and over 150 rescued in the tennessee
valley
as heavy rainfall swamped the area
flooding homes and roads
including parts of nashville the
president and the white house continue
to monitor the situation very closely
and stand at the ready should any
federal uh
federal uh federal assistance be
requested or required
at this time no requests for federal
assistance have come in
the national weather service reports
over nine inches of rain
has fallen over the past 24 hours of
course causing this
massive flooding jonathan why don't you
kick us off thanks um
the cdc director today delivered an
impassioned warning against a rise in
colby cases and said it filled with a
sense of quote
impending doom we're seeing cases rise
in many
states my question is does the president
plan out to reach
directly to governors including the
democratic governors of states like new
york
new jersey and michigan that are seeing
real rises
this plan to ask them to slow down or
pause them reopening
their states well jonathan we are in
very close touch
with governors of those states and
states across the country not only
through our weekly governor's call that
is led by our covid coordinator
but through calls and engagements that
happen through the course of the week
and through the course of every day
and the president has not held back in
calling for
uh governors leaders uh the american
people
to continue to abide by the public
health guidelines whether they are
mass mandates on federal land buildings
or on interstate
travel whether it's uh you know
encouraging people to
hand wash and abide by social distancing
he will continue to do that
through all of his engagements and of
course through calls he has with local
officials but we are in very close touch
with leaders across the country
but this is probably the most precarious
moment the country's had in terms of
virus since the president took office
according to cdc direct cbc director
today will the president not take that
additional step to get to
talk to governors and ask them to slow
down the reopenings well jonathan
the president uses every opportunity he
can whether it's public
publicly uh through every interview
through nearly every public engagement
he has he has
remarks later this afternoon as you know
on kovid
providing an update on our effort to
defeat the virus
he also does that through private
engagements as well but
there are a range of officials at very
high levels who are in touch with
governors and leaders
across the country who will continue to
emphasize the need to abide by public
health guidelines and one other topic
uh majority leader schumer is making the
case that budget reconciliation can be
used
uh once more in the fiscal year of 2021
if the senate apologizes argument
this could be used a couple more times
over the next year or so does the white
house support that move
and what would it mean for the
president's agenda well the white house
and the president will leave the
mechanics of bill passing
to leader schumer and other leaders in
congress
our focus is on proposing an agenda an
ambitious agenda
to invest in infrastructure to help
caregivers across the country
uh to ensure that we are doing more to
help americans get through this
challenging period of time
go ahead thanks jen um on infrastructure
since the president is set to unveil his
proposal in a couple of days now
what is his current thinking or his
economic advisors current thinking on
how much of this package
needs to be paid for with tax revenue
well
the president has a plan to fix the
infrastructure of our country we're
currently 13th in the world no one
believes we should be there
and he has a plan to pay for it which he
will propose uh
but right now once he proposes that our
focus is also on
having that engagement and discussion
with members of congress
if they share a goal of building our
infrastructure for the future but don't
like the way he's going to propose to
pay for it
we're happy to look at their proposals
if they don't want to pay for it i guess
they can propose that too
maybe they don't support infrastructure
spending so the president
has an ambitious goal the most important
thing is to
figure out how to uh invest in put
forward the investments in our much
needed
uh that are much needed in our
infrastructure what's irresponsible is
not to address the urgent needs
of that investment but the means and
mechanisms of paying for it
we look forward to presenting his plans
but also hearing proposals
for others who may have a difference of
view is there a concern that if you
don't pay for
enough of it that it'll have a drag on
the economy specifically by increasing
the
debt and deficit uh well again he's
going to have a plan to pay for it i'm
sure that
if there are proposals out there that
are differing from his in terms of what
they will cover
we'll have that discussion uh but he of
course uh
believes that investing in our
infrastructure continuing to create
good paying union jobs is front and
center but he also believes that we have
an opportunity to
rebalance to take uh to address our tax
code that is out of date
and uh and and uh some could pay more in
our country that are not currently
and on that front just a clarification
last week you said the tax increase
threshold
for the president is four hundred
thousand dollars a year both for
individuals and households is that
correct yep
and what uh does the white house say to
moderates who might be concerned that
hiking the corporate tax rate to say 28
will be a drag on growth uh we haven't
seen
evidence in that from economists but if
they have alternative proposals to how
to for how to pay for
investing in our nation's infrastructure
rebuilding our roads and our railways
and
putting uh americans back to work we're
happy to hear it and then finally on the
vaccine
andy slavic talked about the idea of a
vaccine passport uh in the kovic
briefing this morning he said it's
primarily going to be spearheaded by the
private sector but
what's the president's position on
whether once the vaccine is more readily
available
businesses should be able to tell
employees who don't want to get the
vaccine for
whatever reason that they can't come
back into the workplace or
that airlines could reject people from
getting on the plane if they
have decided not to get a vaccine well
we're going to provide guidance
just as we have through the cdc uh
there's currently
an interagency process that is looking
at many of the questions around vaccine
verification
and that issue will touch many agencies
as
verification is an issue that will
potentially touch many sectors of
society as you have
certainly alluded to um that's guidance
we'll provide we expect as
andy slavitt i think alluded to that a
determination or development of
a vaccine passport or whatever you want
to call it
will be driven by the private sector
ours will more be
focused on guidelines that can be used
as a basis and
are there a couple key principles that
we are working from one is that
there will be no centralized universal
federal vaccinations database
and no federal mandate requiring
everyone to obtain a single vaccination
credential
second we want to encourage an open
marketplace with a variety of private
sector
companies and non-profit coalitions
developing solutions
and third we want to drive the market
toward meeting public interest goals so
we'll leverage our resources
to ensure that all vaccination
credential systems meet key standards
whether that's universal accessibility
affordability availability both
digitally and on paper but those are our
standards currently going through an
interagency process we'll make some
recommendations and then
we believe it will be driven by the
private sector and when do you
anticipate those guidelines
will come out i don't have a timeline to
provide you at this point but it's
obviously something we're working
through
and we want to provide that clarity to
the public good
i want to talk about george floyd will
the president be
watching or receiving updates on derek
shawn's trial today and has he been in
touch with george floyd's family in the
lead trial
well he certainly will be watching
closely as americans across the country
will be watching
uh you know at the time of um
george floyd's death he talked about
this as being
uh a an event that really opened up a
wound
uh in the american public uh and it
really
uh brought to light for a lot of people
in this country
uh just the kind of racial injustice and
inequality that many communities are
experiencing every single day
and he'll be watching it closely he'll
certainly be provided updates
obviously this is a trial that's working
its way through a law enforcement
or a legal process so we wouldn't weigh
in further than that but
these were events that at the time he
spoke about as
uh being just a reminder of also the
need to and it certainly impacted how
he's thought about
in his own government making equity
central to what we do
instituting and putting in place uh uh
racial injustice and addressing racial
injustice as a priority one of the key
crises that he
believes he is facing and we are all
facing as a country so we
will continue to be central to what we
do and he will of course be watching the
trial closely
to the family of george floyd in the
lead-up to the trial uh
not i don't have any calls to read out
he obviously spoke to them or not
obviously for those of you who didn't
follow this closely he did speak to them
uh last spring uh and
spoke at the time and comment at the
time about their grace
and i know he conveyed that he was just
impressed by their courage
and he continues to believe that you
said it redoubled his commitment to
advancing racial justice in this country
he also committed
to creating this national police
oversight commission during his first
100 days in office has that been created
yet is that so on track to being created
well we're encouraged um first by the
interest and engagement by
members of the house and senate in the
george floyd bill uh which
uh we is making progress and there's
discussions that are active at this
point in time
that's really where our focus is going
to be uh at this moment
uh we believe that and he believes i
should say that it is imperative to um
put in place to re in order to rebuild
trust among communities
uh that there needs to be accountability
uh and there needs to be
um systems in place to ensure that and
laws changed
to ensure that that can be carried out
uh so
that is where our focus is the president
supports that uh piece of legislation uh
and uh we're hopeful that
uh he will be able to he will receive a
landmark reform bill on his desk
the commission still be established in
his first 100 days in office
i don't have any update on it other than
to convey that this bill is an
opportunity to put in place a number of
the actions that
uh that he that many in the advocacy
community
uh feel are imperative at this point in
our countries
i don't have any update on the timeline
but i think what's important to note
is that the george floyd bill uh which
would
put in place and make law a number of
the accountability measures and actions
that
he and so many who watch these events in
horror feel are imperative at our this
point in our country one last question
if i could
uh jen thank you um i want to just turn
to immigration really quickly here
uh president joe biden has said the
surges like this happen every year we
know
uh that these cycles do happen axios is
reporting
uh that they have received documents
that show the surge of miners coming to
the southern border is expected to last
seven or more months i just got back
from the border i spoke with texas state
troopers who said they have never seen
this many unaccompanied minors crossing
the united states border are you guys
tracking that timeline for this current
surge that it's going to
last seven months or more well what
we're working to do
is put in place uh steps and actions to
help
address the situation at the border
including of course
expediting processing and opening up
additional shelters
but also reinstituting policies like the
central american miners program
to encourage young people to apply in
their country
and not make that treacherous journey we
are also in a circumstance where we are
uh digging out of a broken system uh
over the past four years not just the
inhumane policies
but the fact that there were never
efforts put in place to
uh look for us and seek shelters where
these children could be
safely and humanely housed they had a
different policy than
the president has of course but also
there was a hiring freeze
at orr in the refugee resettlement
office which made it something that we
had to also dig
out of when we started so that's where
our focus is on
uh we are hopeful that as we put these
uh in place these measures we can help
to
address and stem the challenges at the
border
here is the administration expecting a
surge in unaccompanied minors over the
next several months
i don't have any predictions those would
certainly come from cbp or the
department of homeland security
but our focus now is on ensuring that we
have enough shelters facilities
to house unaccompanied children we just
opened three last week
that would allow for almost 7 000
additional beds so that's what our focus
is in at this point in time we'll leave
the projections to other agencies
go ahead thanks jen just a couple
follow-ups on the commission there was
some talk that would be among the first
things that he did in his first week or
two in office did something happen
that kind of took that off the table and
took your focus more
towards the legislative efforts no i
think uh it's just a reflection of our
i just don't have an update on it but we
are working with uh very closely with
outside advocacy groups uh with many who
have been passionately fighting for
greater accountability and greater
reforms to be put in place and we're
looking for
the most effective means to get that
done and the george floyd bill is an
opportunity to do exactly that so that's
where we are putting our energy and
efforts at this point
and then we'll follow up on nancy's
first question are you saying the
entirety of the president's proposal
laid out on wednesday you will have paid
for mechanisms
dollar for dollar across the board
certainly yep
okay and then um the forthcoming who
report i know some people
have drafts of it do you put in does the
administration put any stock into it
whatsoever given how it was put together
and also
is the u.s working in a parallel wave
via its intelligence community its
public health officials
to produce its own conclusions about the
origins of chromebooks well
it's a little early for that last piece
right now but let me give you an update
on kind of where we are
uh the report under embargo of course is
now
in the hands of u.s government experts
from the cdc
fda nih hhs usda dhs
and usaid that is a lot of acronyms 17
experts long-standing leaders in the
fields including
epidemiology public health clinical
medicine veterinary medicine infectious
disease
law food security biosafety biosecurity
we have a lot of experts in government
we'll be reviewing this report
intensively and quickly
and we have some of our best people in
government focused on reviewing it
uh right now uh we are also
communicating closely with our partners
and allies around the world to share our
ongoing concerns
which we have stated in the past of
course about the process
and our scientific analysis of the
report itself once these individuals
have concluded
uh their review we will wait for that
review to
conclude we have been clear that an
independent
technically sound investigation is what
our focus is on and once this is
reviewed we'll have an assessment about
the steps forward
okay and then last one a number of house
committees last week
sent uh letters to i think 16 different
agencies and the white house about
uh sending over documents of any
communications in the lead up to january
6 and lead up to the joint session
do you guys plan to cooperate with that
inquiry and will you be responding both
from the white house side and on the
agency side with that
i'm sure we will be cooperating with
congress but i also know there are many
documents that some believe we have here
that may not be here they might be in
the archives so i think we'll have to
look and see
what documents they are i'll talk to our
counsel's office and see
what our expectation is at this point in
time go ahead
um two questions jen on the campaign the
president talked
about how um and his aides held the view
that spending on traditional
infrastructure like roads and bridges
did not necessarily have to be paid for
because it created jobs
and i'm wondering if you could just talk
about if if he still has that view and
how the package unveiled on wednesday
will balance
that view of spending versus tax
increases
well i think we'll have more to say
about it once we actually roll out
the package um but i think what i wanted
to note today and what we want to make
clear
is that the president has a plan to fix
our infrastructure and a plan to pay for
it but we are also open to contin having
that discussion
we certainly expect to have the
discussion with members of congress
as we move forward about areas where
they agree where they disagree where
they would like to see greater emphasis
or not
so we'll look forward to having that
conversation once the plan's announced
on wednesday
and just one more thing um on friday the
white house announced that it was
nominating gail manchin
senator joe manchin's wife for the job
of federal co-chair of the appalachian
regional commission
this is a group responsible for steering
um millions of dollars in states like
west virginia
that nomination came as a surprise to
some people on the hill
and i'm wondering if you could talk a
little bit about the process by the way
has settled on gail mentioned
and what type of input senate or senator
manchin had in that
i'll have to follow up with our
personnel team on the exact process
there but we can do that for you after
the briefing
go ahead jeff thanks jeff the ship that
was stuck in the suez canal has been
freed
i'm sure the white house has been
monitoring that do you have any sense of
what economic impact that week-long
little bit more than week-long
event is going to have uh well my
understanding is it's been freed but
it's not yet open
right the canal and that will still
happen and there are of course ships
waiting to pass through the canal uh
we of course are monitoring and we'll be
assessing the impact but i don't have
anything to update you on
that from here okay um
wonky question alert okay i like that i
like the preview
the stocks are falling today because on
wall street because of the default of a
hedge fund
is this something that the white house
is monitoring and do you have any
concerns about
i would send you to the sec on that um
for any further
comments but we uh of course are
monitoring as an administration
uh less walking do you have any updates
on the white house is thinking about
sanctions uh against myanmar and
reaction to the latest deaths and
kevin's there sure
let me let me give you a reaction and
also uh because we haven't talked about
this that much in here
recently an update on some of our recent
actions um
we're deeply concerned by the recent
escalation of violence against peaceable
protesters in burma
burmese security forces are responsible
for hundreds of deaths in burma since
they
perpetrated a coup on february 1st we
condemn this abhorrent violence against
the burmese people
the burme their burmese junta continues
to use lethal force against its own
people
last week's killing of children is just
the most recent example
of the horrific nature of the violence
perpetrated by the military regime we
continue to make clear
that we will impose costs on the
military regime for the deadly violence
against
peaceful protesters and the suppression
of human rights
today ustr announced the suspension of
all u.s
engagement with burma under the 2013
trade and investment framework agreement
effective immediately the suspension
will remain in effect until the return
of democratically elected government
additionally the sanctions on
military-owned holding companies
nbc and mehl where we announced last
week
are the most significant action since
the february first coup to impose costs
on the military regime
we've also announced a number of actions
by the department of commerce
new export controls on burma and added
four burmese entities to the entity list
and response to the military coup and
violent crackdowns
we of course continue to work with our
allies and partners in like-minded
institutions as we condemn the actions
of the military
call for the immediate restoration of
democracy and hold those who seize power
accountable
very last one um also the follow-up to
the cdc
and white house speaking this morning on
kobet
they made very clear that they are
urging americans
to continue to take action to prevent a
fourth surge
including non-essential travel is the
warning against non-essential travel
something that the white house is taking
into consideration with regard to
upcoming travel by the president and
vice president
both for business and for personal uh
reasons
well i would say that the president
travels as does the vice president
on a private plane that is the purview
of every president vice president
throughout
american history that is of course
different
than traveling on a commercial flight
and going to mass events as you know we
don't the president is not hosting
rallies nor is the vice president we
take uh
the role of um sending being models
uh quite seriously uh but i think most
americans would recognize the difference
go ahead thanks jim um just on a
clarification on the pay for questions
sure when you said that it would be paid
a dollar for dollar
that the infrastructure component would
be paid for dollar per dollar were you
applying that
also to the entirety of the package that
will be released both wednesday and
in april or i just want to make sure
we're understanding what's what we paid
for
well uh i think we're focused focused
right now i should say on the wednesday
proposal
obviously there's still more that's
being worked through but i can for the
proposal later in the month
like i should say next month um which is
still being
worked working its way through an
economic team but i can assure you that
when the president
lays out his infrastructure plan uh he
will also
lay out a plan to pay for it um but is
again open to ideas and proposals from
members of congress if they have a
difference of view and there was an
op-ed in the new york times today by a
well-known virologist
the title we can't end the pandemic
without vaccinating kids the argument is
basically that
over time there will be mutations that
could be more dangerous for children
what is the administration doing to
prepare for the possibility of
vaccinating children
and does the president have a specific
time period for when he would like to
see
children begin to get the vaccine well
we leave that to our health and medical
experts and
the fda uh process uh and cdc i should
say
process of uh outlining guidelines uh
for
when it is safe uh to utilize the three
approved vaccines or which one is the
best for children
so we will rely on the advice and
counsel of our health and medical
experts on that
and just one more when should we expect
the president to announce his next slate
of judicial nominees
i don't have a preview or an update for
you stay tuned
can you just say can you give us any
insight into the process behind the
scenes about you know who's leading that
process internally
how are you coming up with this late i
think there are 68 or so vacancies right
now
uh you know i can convey that the
president wants to
nominate people who have who are
qualified who have
a breath of experience who bring
perspective to
these roles and obviously he seeks to
meet his own bars of diversity when he's
nominating
any individuals to serve in his
administration uh but we'll look forward
to
discussing further at the point when
we're ready to announce nominees
um if i could just quickly follow my
jeff's question sure is it the white
house position that the cdc
travel guidelines don't apply to a
private plate
i think the president he was asking me
specifically about the president's
travel and the vice president's travel
uh and the specifics of the guidelines
you can certainly ask the cdc for
further clarification but what i'm
conveying
is that president and as any president
does travels on air force one whether he
is traveling
to uh visit a community in this country
or whether he is traveling
to go to his home state of delaware i
think most people recognize that
uh as being a difference um but if i
could um ask a foreign policy question
sure uh ethiopia um senator coons
recently traveled to
addis on behalf of the president um
since then we've seen
uh prime minister abbey uh announced
plans for the withdrawal of eritrean
streets from
tigre i mean if do you have some
reaction on that
and is that something that president
biden was demanding
uh well first we are uh grateful to
senator coons for traveling to ethiopia
on behalf of president biden
we appreciate the time and the
liberation of the president the prime
minister i should say
we're encouraged by the prime minister's
announcement that the government of the
state of eritrea has agreed to withdraw
its forces from ethiopia
the immediate and complete withdrawal of
eritrean troops from tigre will be an
important step in de-escalating the
conflict and restoring regional peace
and stability we hope both governments
will make good on this commitment on the
ground urgently
certainly it was a part of the
discussion that senator coons uh
traveled there to communicate about um
and if i may i'm just quickly
on the the president's health he he last
released a comprehensive health report
in
2019 during the campaign can we expect
him to make a trip to walter reed soon
for his physical and and will you commit
to
releasing a comprehensive health report
in the near future
absolutely i don't have a timeline but
absolutely we will do that and
um i'll check and see when he's due to
go back to the doctor
go ahead hi ken sake rachel sutherland
yeah i'm pretty sure i want to follow up
on juan gonzalez's recent trip to
guatemala
what kind of progress is to make i
understand that ambassador jacobson also
with the next company of guatemala as
well
what kind of progress on addressing the
root causes of mass migration can you
give us
well i think this was their first trip
we just announced an envoy as well
to the region which shows our focus and
emphasis
on addressing the root causes and of
course the vice president of the united
states will be
uh helping lead that effort specifically
the root causes not the border there's
some confusion over that
um they i don't have i know we did a
readout after the uh
meetings and the trips last week i don't
have additional uh an additional readout
for you
other than to convey that we know this
will be a diplomatic process
our view is it's not if but when we work
through with these countries the best
ways we can work together to address
root causes
and the president has also proposed an
immigration bill that includes
uh 400 billion dollars in funding to
help address the root causes as well
and help ensure that families and
individuals who are making this trip are
incentivized to stay in their countries
i've heard some talk about the sponsor
families for the children who are in
uh the care of hss any idea of how
that's going to be set up
and the vetting process for some of
these sponsored families
some of them may be family members as
we've heard
but it's been a question as to who are
the
the sponsors that would take them in and
how will that work
so um one of the issues we've been
trying to address
is that uh they shouldn't all be treated
exactly the same and obviously if it's a
mother or a father or a biological
family member
that's different um there are a number
of steps vetting steps that are taken is
that what you're asking about
yeah that are taking these people that
are going to be taking in the children
well it really differs sometimes there
are community groups uh there are
religious
organizations there are individuals who
have uh been sponsor families in the
past again it doesn't mean that these
children stay in the country this is a
safe place for them to be
while their cases are being adjudicated
but vetting is an important part of
this process because in the past there
have been scenarios where there has been
trafficking we want to of course avoid
that
sometimes that's why it takes a little
bit longer and we're working to expedite
the processing
wherever we can follow up if someone
wants to sponsor
a child any place to go for that if they
they're interested
i i'm sure we can get you the
information for uh the department of
homeland security health and human
services and the program that they are
running and a lot of it is through local
organizations and community groups as
well
go ahead thanks john um on georgia's new
laws restricting voting president biden
called them last week
i think the most pernicious thing uh
does the white house believe now that
the loan has been signed
um that companies or individual
consumers should boycott georgia or
georgia businesses
and what should people do who don't have
a voting congress to vote on
the belief the people of georgia the
people of georgia people across the
country they should elect new leaders
they can
take steps like any any individual can
take
as an american citizen to have their
voice heard and exercise their
their democratic right but does he
believe that that people should boycott
their increasing calls for them
that's not a call we're making from here
go ahead
thank you jen um the vice president said
before that the exodus of women leaving
the workforce
during the pandemic is a national
emergency
um the president has said that we're
dealing with an acute immediate child
care crisis in america i know that
child care is a part of his
infrastructure initiative
um and wednesday we will hear more about
this business in april
you'll hear more well i guess that's my
question why aren't we hearing
uh more about this first before the
physical infrastructure needs given that
it's such an emergency and given that
we're
in a situation right now where women are
in desperate families are in desperate
need of
child care assistance well the president
and the vice president agreed that's why
they pushed so hard to get the american
rescue plan
passed that ensured that millions of
families
could get funding through the child tax
credit
could get fourteen hundred dollar checks
uh out to
uh a large number of families across the
country a hundred million which have
already
gone out uh why the earned income tax
credit was something he fought to have
in there as well
but he believes that that's not enough
and we need to do more
and so he's looking forward to in a
couple of weeks laying out more
specifics
of his plan to do exactly that
good so the white house office of
science and technology policy announced
this formation
task force to investigate past um
tampering with science decisions in the
white house and i'm wondering um
what was sort of the thinking behind
forming that task force and what do you
guys hope to find or accomplish
with it well the president issued a
memorandum
on scientific integrity and
evidence-based policy making
directing agencies to make
evidence-based decisions guided by the
best available
science and data and so this task force
will be taking a whole government
approach
to reinstate science across federal
agencies and ensure that it is part of
how decision making
is made they're going to examine
policies that were antithetical to that
mission over the last four years
and also look ahead and ensure it's
integrated as we move forward
we're just starting we're just
inaugurating that process
and it's just as evidence that the
president believes that scientific
integrity
matters and it should be central to how
we approach governing
is there a punitive aspect to it like
are you trying to find wrongdoing
wrongdoers and punish them in some way i
think the focus is on ensuring that our
policies moving forward that
policies that are not meeting that bar
that are still in place
are changed and that we institute this
as uh as central to how we approach
policy making uh in our agencies across
government moving forward
okay and one more um do you have an
update on whether the vice president
plans to travel
to central america or to the border as
part of her looking into the root causes
of the immigration problem i don't have
an update on her travel but since you
gave me the opportunity it's important
to understand and know that she
is focused on addressing root causes in
the region and so travel i would expect
would be there
the border and an expediting processing
at the border
opening shelters ensuring we're moving
kids out of border patrol facilities
that is really under the purview of the
department of homeland security and hhs
and they all work together but
uh the vice president's focus is on the
region root causes and engaging with
governments directly
so if she were to travel it'd be to
central america or something like that
that would be my
expectation but i don't have any travel
to preview at this point in time
i'll go in the back to the blockchain in
myanmar what is
china's role in the crisis of myanmar
and what do you expect
picking or beijing what do we expect
beijing to do
well certainly when we engage with
partners in the region china is one of
those
one of those countries of course in the
region i don't think i have anything
more in terms of calls for action
other than we have worked through the
national security accounts or through
the un security council i should say
through several global entities to
ensure we are sending a clear message as
a global community
about the actions in burma and that we
are taking sanction steps as a
coordinated global community as well
go in the back thank you john um uh
two foreign policy questions sure and a
third one for a colleague uh on
on yemen u.s envoy uh linda king
is currently in oman and having
discussions
uh in order to promote um
a lasting peace and ceasefire in yemen
how are these discussions
i know that he's spent a fair amount of
time on these discussions and working on
addressing and stemming the humanitarian
uh crisis but also uh working towards um
uh some element of a ceasefire of course
in the region uh i would point you to
the state department where he
works directly for any update on the
discussions we're of course receiving
updates here as well
and the second one is on on iran
now that they've signed this long-term
agreement with china
does the administration still have the
same policy towards iran especially in
terms of returning to the
nuclear deal and is the president
willing to partially
some sanctions uh on iran
in exchange of its return to the nuclear
deal
that's not under consideration uh we
remain uh hopeful and focused on
uh returning to a diplomatic approach uh
in partnership with
members of the p5 plus one uh china is
of course a member of that
uh and we uh of course will take a look
at uh
and ensure that any uh sanctions uh that
need to be implemented would be
uh as it relates to this package but we
haven't looked at the
specific agreement yet at this point in
time so
our our approach uh remains the same and
nothing has changed about our approach
the president said that he's been uh
concerned about it for years what did he
mean by that and how concerning is this
for the administration
concerned about i know he was asked a
question yesterday in china the 25
apparently 25 years uh a long-term
agreement between china and iran
well uh china has been a member of the
p5 plus one an important partner as it
related to
getting the deal passed to begin with
certainly would be
an important partner as we look ahead to
a diplomatic approach
at this point in time we're still
working through those
steps and don't have an update on the
engagement
my colleague's question is on north
korea
now that the president said that he's
prepared for some form of diplomacy
with north korea does this include
sitting with president kim jong-un i
think his approach would be quite
different
uh and that is not his intention thank
you
thank you thanks everyone okay
you